[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it's him parking lot on Flatbush and
Vanderbilt in 15 minutes let's go wait
wait
des looks like a dirty criminal but you
look like a cop man you can't go over
there like that
what'd you have in mind don't call it a
comeback
[Music]
I know how we're gonna blend in don't
say thrift stores no store Jake the
overwhelming time pressure yep Jake I
just don't think he's innocent
I just think that it oughta be like a
pile I mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry Scully we only had two uniforms
it's okay for some reason all the fries
and gravy and cheese upset my tummy
[Music]
[Music]
they're doing it what what do you have
to do Don Johnson it
[Music]
like an idiot I didn't even have time to
lotion my forearms they're all so
beautiful and they're all about to be
tested
bouncy styles
[Music]
I love this mattress
i mean--you to unleash the beast
[Music]
let's you guys why smoke your butts
because Ray Ray and thumbies don't even
get all right we don't give a what let's
go out there and gear our asses up you
can't go outside spewing mumps like a
couple of month out uns not like this we
can't
hustling death everyday
stop you can't leave it all good luck
trying to stop us you'll never catch us
you gotta blend in if you like to a
looking good really kind of feel like
I'm Jimmy Buffett's tennis coach no it's
working you know I had a major crush on
magnum p.i major Oh should I grow a
mustache
yeah you should actually I can't I'm
physically incapable I should have
suggested that should we go in Davey
we heard Stevie and I were beat cops
together we called ourselves the beatsie
boys and yeah it was as cool as it
sounds so y'all would just stand around
like that Oh prepare to enter high
society
[Music]
okay how's everybody feeling anyone else
have the weird urge to lecture
themselves Peralta what are you doing
Peralta what are you doing I conjured
him
[Applause]
what I'm only human you can't always
expect me to be the coolest guy ever
coolest guy ever try telling that to
Alan Greenspan nice burn Bob great
everyone looks fantastic and our hats
look normal
Wow Sarge you are just stopped into
those scrubs how do you do it
exercise and diet it's not that hard
yeah seems pretty hard to me I don't
think I'm gonna do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are we gonna fit in there dress like
this no no we're not sign a petition to
make quand or the dragon a male there
are already enough girl characters we
don't need a third no no no like that
adult toys still sounds wrong male toys
you know what let's just not call them
toys that's my fault I started it you
got it we'll just call playthings we
will not let's do this
sniper binoculars here Charles tell me
how far away I am too close to measure
they really work that's everything let's
do this
[Music]
this is making much stuff
yeah and it's too heavy to carry all the
way back yeah
where's mr. Peralta objection
mr. Peralta what is the meaning of this
Your Honor I'd like to call a surprise
witness you're not an attorney
manse come get Master
Vance comes down get mascot man wrap to
sit yeah you gotta rub the six we'll
just have to borrow something Oh No
from who
[Music]
[Music]
what is the bandwidth on the Wi-Fi here
we have much content to stream the hold
on another cold brew don't mind if I
cold do
nailed it I am loving this machine that
Charles brought in it is nice the trick
is to let the coffee warm up the room
temperature I'm already on my second cup
it's my third good too much well what's
going on Charles why are you talking so
slow
[Music]
oh my god if you're not going so that
means we're going fast are we going fast
can I want tell for going fast thing
we're going fast at all anyway
whatsoever I feel like we're going slow
in every way whatsoever kept not even
great excellent amazing I feel better
than I've ever felt at a moment in my
life so we're all fine yep yep
you